number one it's a simplified right make
it closer to get a nicer more succinct
concise form who agrees with 4x plus 2
and it's up straight heads up
wonderful thank you hands down looks
good to me
common errors when you have a look at a
question like this let's just focus it
on this some bit a big beginning 3x plus
2x I often see students who sing this
will say 3 plus 2 that's fine
and then X and X I know what happens
when it's X and X it's x squared now my
question to you is why is cuz Gerrans my
appreciations a queen right why does
Jarrod's punch right and why is this one
no valid if anyone gives me an
explanation not just a rule but an
explanation as to why it's not this okay
all right but hold on a second on a
second
why shouldn't I multiply them together
why you know like if I if you want me to
add them instead then shouldn't it be 5
+ 2 X isn't that what it should be
why isn't it that well you record frame
no no not yet especially because we're
not focused on this right now
by the logic that I just heard right 3
plus 2 is 5 X plus X if you want me to
do addition not modification is to make
so why is it it this someone explaining
why it's not ready cuz we don't know
that so you mean it's about to do with
like a it's a very it's a pruning I
don't know what's there hmm so does that
mean sometimes I can do that it
sometimes I call it like if I knew the
number could I do that but why not you
told me it's not multiplication okay
I'm alright with that but if you add the
3 in the two why don't you
Exodus this is a really important
question yeah what do you want X like
symbolizes five times so you talking
about just these guys be fine okay okay
oh I might get one more try for Maria
that's interesting I've had lots of
right things but so far no one's
actually explained to me why I shouldn't
add these ones and then add those ones
so far you know explanation what do you
reckon now can I just suggest by the way
I didn't ask for all laptops to be down
and pens out of hands thank you
this is a really important moment this
year we have learned algebra algebra is
a super power it's a super heart that
lets you do with all numbers when you
don't even know what they learned bless
you but if all our tree is too is a set
of rules right
like I follow them because teacher said
so textbook says so that's how you get
the ax in the back you don't really get
why like no one has really given me a
successful argument as to why it's not
this you added the three of the two
that's how you've got five do you agree
with that so why don't you add the exits
okay I'll give you my explanation as to
why I'll write maybe maybe when you've
got your arm working yeah and you should
definitely bring the question about if
you have by now so all that should be
given to you here's my explanation as to
why those first two terms do become 5 X
and not 5 lots of 2x let me ask you this
question
3x it's shorthand it's shorthand the way
don't or wasn't a short hair they're an
abbreviation what's don't an
abbreviation do you like big good so I
omitted the oh right what about this one
wasn't ok so again now 3x something has
been omitted what's been remitted
cushing multiplication this is 3 times
x3 lots of X right which means I should
be able to rewrite 3x as X plus X what's
next did you agree right
aha ok I think gears turning now do you
see why you can explain it it's not this
if 3x is that what's two men there are
five things there what are they
five X's not five two x's right so this
is really important it's not just a rule
that someone told you you add these but
not these right what you need to think
of is what is it actually right
what is this
shorthand for cuz it's a powerful
language so long as you actually
understand okay I'm bit more satisfied
now 5x you take away what just just 1x
right wouldn't
again this is shorthand there's a 1 and
there's a multiplication sign that are
both hiding there we don't write them
because we just want a quick other yeah
so you took away one of them which is
why we get 4 and then there's is -
hangry does that make sense
can I go see your courage you just have
a look see the way this isn't set out
here I understand what's going on it's
kind of like what's happening in your
brain but can I encourage you to write
it a little bit differently right um
everyone our right hand side here I'll
should rewrite the question if you
haven't already
he's how I'm gonna sit down I've got 3x
plus 2x X okay now is this equal to 3
plus 3 minus 1 is that is that the same
as this so there are two problems with
these right your cheekbones number one
see this plus two this guy over here
what happened to him he just he just
disappeared good right and then and then
you notice he made us he made a sneaky
reappearance he did come back right but
if he goes away and comes back then this
is a really true reason right it's like
it's like kind of equals right fat but
not really okay this is the first
problem law is the other problem that's
the first one what's the other thing
that's disappeared yeah the exes of all
just vanish now I get why cuz we're
thinking about the numbers this is a
major thing in the cat too as well she's
not ready to give Betty today but I want
to point it out right now two weeks
if I want to say these things are really
equal I'm really literally okay to do
this a long time like I don't mean that
as a punishment thing I just mean that
as a run out of time thing I map it out
the conversation we do I mean anything
last time by expect you probably up and
I really love you to understand this
come out of here with a good understand
is a confident understanding of this but
it takes some time and attention do you
think that's reasonable you seven
you just don't check that do you think
that's reasonable you said yeah okay
that's better let me see you put your
money where your mouth is if you really
want to say that's equals like this
would be please on the right hand side
of this equal sign let's just do this
one step at a time we're just convince
ourselves the 3x plus 2x is truly 5x but
then there are these other things here
so I need to include them otherwise it's
not really equal right that's what that
sign means but I want to keep working on
it I want to keep doing more things with
it so I'm gonna write something else
that's simpler but still equal so I'll
deal with these guys like that and the
plus two just hangs out on the end why
don't I do anything with plus two why
doesn't it get added to the four yeah
very good
I'm Jerry hopefully said yeah these are
like terms it does a similar right there
are X's they mixed together but this guy
here is separate all right we'll do the
rest the questions a little bit quicker
since we draw on that one I don't a
little bit this in fact I think you'll
find is actually to not to X let me try
and convince you again I'm gonna do with
working out so on the top it's for X
what is this time and again what does
that mean
it's division right so I'm dividing by
whatever this is 3x takeaway X now you
can see here right if I gave you just a
fraction 4 over 2 just by itself you
don't tell me that it's true right now
remember X can be anything X community
let's suppose extra 10 suppose X is 10
even to 10 the numerators gonna be if X
is 10 did not turn on it it's gonna be
20 it's still gonna be too isn't it
right
what if X were 100 400 on 200 what if X
for a million okay you get the idea
right it's always whatever X is it's
always gonna be - okay now this last one
I think something that has gone a little
funny
partly because I feel like our answer is
bigger than what we started with
but I'm subtracting so let me try and do
this I don't know what the answer is yet
by the way let's try and do this
together
what do you think the first problem is
with these guys I can figure least two
yeah okay that's a bit gross right so
let's get them both how about we get
them both actually which would you
prefer we can tip both we give you I by
me do you want both mixed numerals or
both improper fractions which would you
prefer
improper all right let's do it so what
is this as an improper fraction 4 times
2 8 plus the 3
now what isn't it - you're right yeah
now what yeah what it takes a good
choice for denominator 20
I think feather bright so that's 55 on
20 take away
low 28
HD 5 take away 28 okay okay right yeah
yeah you add an edit which is an easy
mistake to make
1 + 7 xx 1 + 7 xx okay let's roll that
up